Oh J Simpson's time in prison could come
to a close as early as tomorrow the
former football star was granted parole
in July he's been locked up in Nevada
since 2008 following an armed robbery
conviction Simpson has said he'd like to
return to Florida but now that state's
attorney general is trying to block the
move and as Jamie yuccas shows us his
already controversial release is getting
more complicated I'd just like to get
back to my family friends and believe me
I do have some real friends after nearly
a decade behind bars former football
star and celebrity defendant OJ Simpson
will soon be a free man mr. Simpson I do
vote to grant parole when eligible and
that will conclude this hearing
thank you a parole board granted his
release back in July after hearing
testimony from Simpson himself his
daughter and one of the victims from the
2007 botched robbery
that landed him in prison although
Simpson apologized for the crime he
didn't hesitate to defend his actions
basically it's been a constant but
Simpson has been in the spotlight for
decades it was 23 years ago that he
became the prime suspect in the double
murder of his ex-wife Nicole Brown
Simpson and her friend Ronald Goldman in
Los Angeles cause of death has been
established as multiple sharp force
injuries and stab wounds today my office
filed murder charges against OJ Simpson
and following his infamous car chase
Simpson was put on trial a courtroom
drama seen by more than a hundred and
fifty million Americans if it doesn't
fit you must acquit in the end he was
found not guilty not guilty of the crime
of murder
[Applause]
oh my god is she dead recently a string
of TV films have reignited America's
fascination with Simpson's life his
early 90s trial highlighted the
country's fascination with celebrity
justice and race themes still relevant
more than two decades later people were
Sheeran OJ Simpson / say they were
cheering what it seemed that the
criminal justice system balanced in
favor of a black person as for Simpson's
future he says he'd like to go back to
Florida where he's lived before but even
the slightest parole violation could
land him right back in prison
I expect it will only be a short period
of time before he will be in the public
eye again shooting off his mouth and at
some point I assume getting in trouble
again
for CBS this morning Saturday Jamie
yuccas Los Angeles the saga that just
keeps going on it seems yeah you almost
don't know what to say anymore no